As we have already discussed,
we can estimate an unknown
mean of a certain random
variable by generating several
independent samples of that
random variable and taking
their average.
And this procedure is well
justified, because of the weak
law of large numbers, which
tells us that this estimator
converges when n goes to
infinity, in probability, to
the true mean.
Now we can apply this
idea more generally.
Suppose we want to estimate
the expected value of a
function of a random variable
X. Now g of X is itself a
random variable.
So if we have samples
of g of X, we can
use the same procedure.
How do we do that?
We generate independent samples
of X, and these give
us independent samples of g of
X. We use those independent
samples, we average them, and
by the weak law of large
numbers, this quantity, as
n goes to infinity, will
converge in probability to the
expected value of g of X.
We already used an idea of this
form when we tried to
estimate an unknown variance.
A variance is defined
as an expectation.
And now we can generate samples
of X, many independent
samples, calculate
this quantity,
and take the average.
However, we might not know the
mean of the distribution.
So instead of the true mean,
we use an estimated mean,
which is estimated the usual
way using a sample average.
So when n is large, this
estimated mean is
close to the true mean.
So using the estimated mean
here will not make a
substantial difference.
And then we have essentially
independent
samples of this quantity.
And by averaging them, we obtain
an estimate of the
variance, which asymptotically,
as n goes to
infinity, will be equal
to the true variance.
Now we can push this
idea even further.
Suppose we wish to estimate
a covariance.
What's a natural way
of doing this?
We can generate independent
samples of the pair of the
random variables X and Y, so
this will be a typical
independent sample, and replace
the expected value by
a sample average.
That is, we take our i-th
sample, i-th pair, and
calculate this quantity, which
looks very much like the
quantity in here except that
we're using the estimated
means in place of
the true means.
We obtain these quantities and
average n of them, again using
the weak law of large numbers.
One can argue that this estimate
will converge to the
true value of the covariance
as n goes to infinity.
And once we have estimates of a
covariance and of variance,
then we can use that to
estimate correlation
coefficients.
Look at this formula, which
is the definition of the
correlation coefficient.
If we just replace all
quantities involved here by
corresponding estimates, this
gives us an estimate of the
correlation coefficient.
All of these ways of forming
estimates can be shown.
We are omitting the details of
the argument, but hopefully
you get the idea by now.
All of these quantities are
consistent estimators.
That is, when the sample size
goes to infinity, they
approach the correct values of
what we're trying to estimate.
So this is just an opening of
what else a statistician might
be interested in.
And if you're wondering what's
the further agenda after this
point, it would be something
like the following.
Typically, a statistician might
to want to say as much
as possible about
the probability
distribution of an estimator.
For example, we have here an
estimate of a covariance.
This estimate is going to be a
random variable because it is
determined by random
quantities.
What is the probability
distribution of this quantity?
Can we describe it
approximately?
What is the mean squared error
associated with this estimator?
And if you wish to construct
confidence intervals how
would you do it?
These are all topics that
statisticians have studied in
depth, and you could see more
about these topics if you were
to take a further class on
statistics and inference.
But we will not go any deeper
in this course.